[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
May 11th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
the summer travel season is almost here
but long delays in getting a passport
could derail your plans to travel
internationally wsj travel reporter
Alison pulley joins us so Allison what's
holding up this process and why has it
been going on for so long A lot of
people are planning to travel
internationally this summer and that
means they are renewing their passports
or applying for them for the first time
so the state department says it's seeing
an average of 500 000 applications per
week
and the number of applications it's
received are 30 to 40 percent higher
than they were in 2022 that means there
are a lot of people applying but the
department is struggling with staffing
issues so during the pandemic people
were not applying for passports that
meant the department let go of
contractors and reassigned other
Personnel they're still building back
they're authorizing a ton of overtime
opening up satellite offices but they're
struggling to keep up with demand does
this delay apply to new passports and
renewals and what should applicants
expect if you are applying for routine
processing that means the standard
processing the application will take 10
to 13 weeks to process
and that doesn't include the time that
it takes to be mailed back to you which
adds up to two weeks wow 10 to 13 weeks
what's the normal time that is the
normal time right now but before the
pandemic it could take five to seven
weeks for a routine application
there's also the option to expedite your
passport and right now expedited
renewals are taking seven to nine weeks
whereas previously they took three to
four weeks so what's the cost involved
here to get a passport and to expedite
it so the cost for a passport book which
is what you'd be using if you were
getting on an international flight is a
hundred thirty dollars to expedite it
you'll pay an additional sixty dollars
and then for people who've already got
their passport maybe they got it years
ago are they in the clear a lot of
destinations won't admit you if your
passport expires within six months and
that's because of different Visa issues
for how long tourists are allowed to be
there so given the current processing
times and these International rules you
should renew your passport nine months
to a year before the expiration date if
you don't want to be panicking so
between all these delays and those
built-in expiration date issues it
sounds like there's a lot of planning
here that Travelers need to do there is
and so if you are looking at your
passport and realize oh my gosh it
expires in July or in August what should
I do
well you can try to have your passport
processed through the Urgent travel
designation and that applies to people
who are traveling internationally within
nine weeks they might not have applied
yet and you can call the passport
information center and make an
appointment to try to move the process
along more quickly Allison there are
some third-party companies that say
they'll expedite the passport process
how reliable are they it depends on the
company so some will tell you that they
can process the passport on their own on
their website without involving the
state department that is not true those
companies are a scam and any company
claiming that they can just do it on
their own without the state Department's
involvement is not reliable but there
are other companies like Rush my
passport which is a courier service that
is registered with the state
Department's National hand carry program
and that means they can submit passport
applications to approved offices on your
behalf if you can't get there yourself
and we often hear about the global entry
program as a service for people who are
traveling internationally what is that
and what does it allow travelers to do
so when you return from an international
trip you have to go through passport
control where you talk about where
you've been why you're coming into the
us if you're a citizen you know where
you're going after you come back and
then eventually you have to go to
customs and talk about anything that you
purchased or anything that you're
declaring so Global Entry allows you to
skip those long lines it's for people
who are considered low risk meaning they
don't have a criminal history and
they've been approved but you have to
have an interview with the Customs and
Border Protection Officer before you can
be enrolled in the program has that
application process also been slowed
down yes a lot of people are applying
for this program because they want to
skip the line they don't want to wait
for hours after returning from a really
long international flight so again the
staff have been struggling to keep up
with demand and getting an interview has
been one of the more challenging parts
of this process so we have this Log Jam
of high demand and low Staffing any word
as to when we'll start to see things
even out and we can get back to what it
was before the pandemic with the state
department they are authorizing a ton of
overtime they're working on hiring more
people they're opening satellite offices
so they have assured everyone that they
are working on Staffing up but the best
thing you can do if you have a trip
coming up this year is to expedite your
passport or if you've missed the window
of seven to nine weeks look into the
Urgent travel desk resignation to make
sure you can get your passport on time
or maybe plan your vacation to be inside
the good old USA that is also a great
option if it's too late that's Wall
Street Journal travel reporter Allison
Poley and that's your money briefing I'm
J.R Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
foreign
[Music]